hey nicole how are you oh conan i'm
great
uh i had surgery this morning on my
ankle
i still have my hospital bracelets on i
forgot to take them off
that's right that's right you hurt your
ankle what did you do you broke it
i dislocated my ankle and broke my
fibula
because i fell down the stairs
because i'm i don't know i i guess i'm a
little clumsy
okay so there was no like drinking
involved at the time no
unfortunately it's the least interesting
story i was just holding a dress
and then the dress kind of fell down and
i slipped on the dress
a dress was trying to take me out right
you should sue the dress manufacturer
you should sue the people that made the
stairs you should sue gravity
you should sue everybody everybody
should get sued
i'll i'ma sue gravity first
[Laughter]
you know let's talk about something
pandemic i know you
you're someone that likes to have fun
you like to have a good time
how are you entertaining yourself while
you're locked inside what are you doing
a lot of things uh well since i broke my
body
it's a lot of sitting scrolling through
instagram
and buying everything i can find
really i bought a sexy burger costume
uh because why not
[Laughter]
you bought it a sexy burger costume
like the buns the the titty parts the
buns and there's little sesame seeds
and then there's a little burger part at
the bottom and then there's lettuce and
tomatoes
it's very cute here it is and this is
you
in the burger costume and i have to say
it's sexy this is a sexy outfit thank
you
and some people commented they're like
why didn't you get it as a bikini
and i was like it's literally on over my
clothing
it is a bikini so let me ask you would
you ever wear this at the beach
see i don't think i would ever wear it
at the beach because i feel like the
salt water and the sand might ruin it
but i do think i'm going to wear it pole
dancing
and then put a nice jaunty mcdonald's
tune under it like
[Laughter]
i maybe you know what mcdonald's people
might be happy with that they might be
cool with that
yeah and then you get a little something
you get a little paid oh yeah
lots of cheeseburgees oh i meant money
yeah milkshakes no no no no no you don't
want to get paid
the food is fine but you want money from
mcdonald's
no no you don't want to need that